i'll keep following in case she comes
back oh she's coming back she's coming
back maybe she's remembering don't you
remember
don't you remember more laundry poop
she's like nah
[Laughter]
she's like now i'm more interested in
going there
there we go remember oh boy remember hey
remember
there you go
[Laughter]
hot t-shirts yeah
did you find
yeah
yeah
you're like yeah i'm just gonna hang out
in here for a little while
hang on to a pool yeah she's gonna fight
she said don't don't take anything yeah
she's like yeah i got it all established
now i'm gonna sit down here
and then try to look she's all like
chilled out she forgot about laundry
yeah
she's got that kramer effect
putting on hot and hot laundry right out
of that
she's gonna start getting sleepy in
there oh
look at her she's all chilled out
yeah you have a good time in there she's
like what are you doing mommy
yeah
i know you're fit you're just like
look at her face
[Laughter]
yeah
it's so nice and warm
it's so nice and relaxing
and nice and relaxing
and she's like she looks like she was
starting to doze off no
got sleepy huh no not sleepy
did you remember you're ridiculous don't
you remember
[Laughter]
she's like don't take clothes don't take
them yeah
she sees me folding
she's like
running out yeah
well then you say the other day you had
some and it's like she didn't she ran in
but
it was too late it's like she was trying
to roll around and like yeah one shirt
like a couple seconds she missed it
she forgot about this game
a little bit
yeah
because mommy's not bringing the big
warm loads in yeah
every other day because she used to as
soon as she saw you with the back
through it now she's through she done
yeah okay it wasn't a good one it wasn't
a good one why it was warm yeah they
just